hi thanks Alan can you all hear me okay
great the technology is actually working
amazing um I just wanted to give you a
very quick kind of briefing on what
we're doing computer-based math because
of the way which I think it sort of
relates to you know the future of data
science and how we all want to make data
much more usable across the world so let
me um I sort of just talk you through a
little bit of what we're doing here and
hopefully tie it into what's happening
in the rest of the summit so really we
founded computer-based master org to
kind of change move the bar on stem and
particularly math education and it's
kind of a central part of our mission to
globally reform the subject matter not
only its delivery but the subject matter
of these subjects and it's kind of like
a you know math is in a very peculiar
place in the world because at one level
it's really high on the good news if
you're into math and data science and
things raised without the good news is
math is really high only a gerrymander
in most countries as a major school
thing that needs fixing but somehow it's
not doing the job it should be doing the
bad news is in my view that eighty
percent of what's being taught around
the world is sort of the wrong subject
and I want to just to explain the sort
of main theory behind computer-based
mass and and why I believe this though
when you look at maths a very simple way
the very quick summary of this is the
following that maths is really a
four-step process in a sense you're
taking a question in the real
theoretical world you're kind of
defining that question you know if I
talk for too long and you guys are all
stuck in an airtight room how long will
it be to the all suffocate that kind of
question and you're turning it into a
piece of math that it's representing
minutes or you're pulling data in to do
that you're somehow abstracting to
something that you can compute from then
you're computing the answer that's the
step 3 and then you're kind of
interpreting results
taking back the answer from its abstract
form to the real world and the big big
problem in math education in schools
around the world is we're spending
almost all our time teaching people how
to been slept three by hand and what
that does is drown out most of these
other steps and it also means the
problems are much more simple and they
should be and this particular problem in
data science type error is of course
because that largely depends on the
Abdullah wide-scale computation various
ways and so we should be using computers
of course in education self-evidently to
do more of step 3 most of the steps
reuse it by default and we should be
using students to do steps 1 2 & 4
rather than focus on step three and
that's really the point behind what
we're trying to under medical echange
computer-based math so just a zoom out a
bit to sort of you know how does this
relate to the data challenges for
society well I believe you know and a
lot of what would I guess you guys are
talking about tum yes then today are you
know how how do we take available
information and make it truly accessible
and another part of that is how do we
take very average sort of information
and personalize it you know individually
to to what you know you specifically
require and in a sense part of that
picture the thing that most of the
conference is about is you know how do
we make the machines work better to
automate that so how do we make a
machinery end of that so it's much
easier for the human but the other side
of the coin is once the machinery is
better you've also got to get a human
set up to do the analysis better to
understand the skeptical human on the
end to figure out how to use this
machinery optimally and so in a sense
another challenge for society is getting
the citizen to be much more of an
analyst both of a very high level but
also just for the average citizen do
that and now the first time please
Cynthia miss mats we'd be building math
curricula starting to and the first
place that we have actually got a real
solid start earnest is at Estonia where
we have made the
probability and statistics curriculum
for secondary school and this sort of is
to slot into their current maths
curriculum hand to replace the bit that
sort of probability and statistics it's
pretty interesting how different it is
and how much I think it's support some
of the modern data science that really
needs to be gone rather than sort of
very traditional probability theory that
we tend to learn at school and not end
up the hill to do many real problems um
we've got lots to do we got to build a
much of the rest of the curriculum we've
got to consumer eyes so this isn't
something that can run through
governments but also can run more
individually to schools and students we
got to make sure it's Essman comes along
with us because how much we don't like
it assessment is a kind of key driver
what changes and we've also got to
connect encoding education which is
started you know fairly well in the UK
in particular in the u.s. to gain
momentum and in Estonia needless to say
and I think there's a great connection
between what I'm talking about
computer-based maths and what coding is
needs to where Cody needs to go so in a
sense the reason for bringing supper
term to you guys is I'm really hoping
that individually is as you're
interested in this topic and I know many
people come up to me and say they are
and also organizationally if your
organizations are in any way involved in
promoting kind of understanding and of
data and data science and the use of
that from the human as well as the
machine perspective so to speak and it'd
be great if you can be you know be great
to interact with you over of things we
can do together and we actually have a
summit coming up at this time in London
last times in New York in November and
the UM that's a sort of place where when
we pull together everyone who's kind of
got a stake in mass and particularly
people who are really users and drivers
of the use of maths and data particular
you know industry government education
but not just people are traditional mass
education people talking to each other
much wider scope than that to figure out
how we really move this agenda forward I
think we're getting a huge amount of
traction in
around the world it's a slightly longer
a longer go to get them to get all the
governments and people involved but any
help for example we get from industry
and from the university sector and for
people who are real users and drivers of
the use of data is a huge help to
getting this reform going around the
world so the idea is to kind of
unscramble maths into a subject that
really does support to what we what we
need in stem and beyond thanks